So weird. That's so weird. Huh?
You know what it is celebrities now that they have to be in and I'm talking
about celebrities and not comedians, by the way,
comedians seem to have this sort of, well, some comedians are out of touch,
but it feels like the safest thing to be online as a comedian because these
singers and these people who are on, uh, social media,
these actors who just like now are like, okay, let's wrap production.
What do I do? I guess I'll just sing about fried fish in my bathroom,
get the lighting guy. Like it's so weird.
Uh, and also
will lead to something like the Gaga DOE
thing, which is just, wow, wait,
hold on. This is the thing. Hold on. Let me go back to the I,
what did I think I tweeted it? Yeah.
I wrote this made me want to go to a credit gal Gadot, best of gal on Twitter.
We are in this together. We will get through this.
We will get through it together. Yeah. That's the I don't like. It's like, yeah.
Except for the people that die.
A gal Gadot just posted a video of her and her other artists who are also
quarantined because of the COVID 19 singing imagined by John Lennon on Instagram
or on Instagram. Yeah. So I tweeted this,
made me want to go to a crowded dance club and kiss everyone.
Meaning I want to get the Corona virus, but do it look at this, by the way,
let me just go on record. Some of these celebrities. I actually, I really like,
and not that it matters. I'm a piece of, but like a lot of these people on,
on this, I like, I like Gaga doll. I like a lot of these people.
James Martin is a great guy. Sarah Silverman is hilarious.
She's the only one that seems to be on this taking the out of it. We love,
we love, we love Sarah, but, um, yeah,
it's just so weird that they did this and that's fine.
It's so weird that they did that did this.
And it's fine that it's so weird that they did this, but guys, you know,
people are face down in ventilators and Gaga doughs. Like
I got it. I, I got it.
What happened?
Your cousin died and your family is at a work now because of this pandemic,
sit down. I got this.
Let me call nine billionaires.
Do we have a song for you? Hey guys, I got it.
Chill. Get Ashley Benson on the phone. You know what I mean?
I love Ashley Benson by the way, but it's still funny and it's okay.
And it's weird that they did it. Okay. Um, look at this.
There's no heaven.
John Lennon, dude. You know,
John Lennon is obviously he's been he's dead,
but he still went like this own. There.
[Inaudible] easiest future.
Imagine, Oh, the people
[inaudible].
Who's that guy, that guy sells pot. Um, dude,
why are they doing? Why are they doing? Why are they doing this?
It's weird to be that like, dude,
people are dying and out of work and being poor and they're going to be
on the streets because of this. And they're just in their mansions,
singing another song and also singing
badly. How could you, I don't, that's the whole thing.
This goes back to my way early on episode. I don't know what episode is on,
but dude, if you're not a singer,
don't stare into the camera and sing for real and posted on Instagram.
You look like a.
These it's like, you're just at your, in, you know what you are.
You're an Instagram thought. That's what you are.
I don't care who you are in this who are some of these people.
I mean, some of these people are actual singers I guess.
And they sound like this guy.
That sounds good. I don't, I'm an idiot. I don't know who that is.
I'm glad to know.
At least this guy didn't even try that guy from Narcos and game of Thrones.
God's a handsome. Huh? Why is he wearing what Luke Perry would have worn in 92.
I know. Um, ah,
imagine no possessions.
I wish they asked me to do it would have been so cool to be on the ane crowd.
Not even joking. I probably would've done it. That's how dumb I am. I'm like,
Oh, it probably also sounded like a good idea in there. Nah, I wouldn't have,
I wouldn't have done it. I would have been so bummed too,
because it would have been like Gaga DOE got in touch with me through my manager
and she wants me to do.
[Inaudible]. Can we do [inaudible].
That was a mid sentence. Ah. Yeah, dude.
Anyway. Um, how come? Uh,
I'm in a group texts with
Nick's worsen. When you Cummings and Joe Rogan,
they talk about the coronavirus.
We talked about the coronavirus so much and I sent them a picture of my kid and
they didn't respond to it. Yes. It's all good.
I guess we're just talking about serious stuff. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine.
It's fine. It's fine. It's not a big deal. It's fine.
But at least say he looks cute.
Um.
Um, anyway, I can't believe this about, uh, about that. They did that.
I just celebrities left to their own devices without PR like they
don't, they can't be with their PR people to be our people. Oh man.
I can't imagine trying to call, but that's the thing that'll end up like yoga.
We'll get, that'll be a positive for Gaga DOE in like two years, I'll be like,
remember when you did that and you'd be like,
I know it was not so maybe the best idea, but we did it, you know?
And it was a bad idea, but there, whatever I like music. So, and we'll be like,
ah, because she's so beautiful and a good actress.
She really is. I think she's great. Um,
Oh you know what? It should have been dude. Imagine.
The people and then
imagine people. Jeremy Renner.
Yeah. Dude. Jeremy Renner make one by yourself. I'm going to do one by myself.
Imagine, Oh, well how's it start? Okay.
Living out of poverty.
Ooh. And you can imagine the people
on the street and without any possessions,
you can imagine them when they're not called or ha God.
Imagine that they were all the irregular 72 degree temperature.
Nobody is uncomfortable
and all of them have stuff to eat
and no kids are dying or adults are dying.
And most importantly, nobody is dying.
Dude. John.
Travolta, what's his name? John Lennon is in his grave.
Yes. Right now John Travolta. What the?
Life a brain tumor.
If I do whatever, bro.
It's about busting and coming in second and and drinking coffee.
Hey mom, I'm saving the world. I'm on the couch. It's all good.
Do you have any death button?
If you're going to, are you still here?
My phone too far away. I think she already left.
Okay. Can you get, I know to get her, to tell you to get Funyuns.
Can you get death a 10?
I haven't gotten up off the couch.
I got rash.
We need to put a healthy amount of Def on my. It's red. Probably
imagine.
Dude, I like the guy who goes, I forget who does it,
but like I liked the guy goes.
I imagine I'll own the paper.
We'll try to put a rock element into it, do it. I'm rock and roll.
I'm rock and roll. Did you guys know that
Guy put Ajax in his face? That's hilarious. What if you put Ajax in his face,
face, it started to burn his eyes and then I just call it chill. Chill.
I got it.
Imagine all the people standing by a train.
Ooh.
Or however ever it goes. I know zero of those words, except for the word.
Imagine.